[Music]  Isak how are you  yeah very good it's nice to see you  walking around I have to I have to say I  don't know how your cast mates feel  about this but I'm everyone else it has  to trudge and Trek for miles through mud  grime fight their way you know endure  terrible hardships your character is  always lying on a bed of hay on a sled  being carried around do they get jealous  of the fact that you get to rest up so  much  yeah well this season especially I had  this really cozy sled yeah I got to rest  it was like a sleeping bag rolled up  with mattresses so I would just chill in  there they'd be like oh no you can have  a break now and I said no let me let me  stay in now of course you have scenes  where you're your character has gone to  another place and then you are walking  how would you find acting in that  situation when you're so used to acting  while lying down now like leg acting is  a terrifying you've got to learn leg is  important  you